.
* Melodie:
Extreme mit "More Than Words" *
# Laliatda dadidadada
# More than nerds
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2019)
Freunde der Sonne,
dieses Video wurde inspiriert
von der wundervollen Bina
und ihrem neuen Format "Kopfstimme".
Nur dass Pina weiß,
wie es richtig geht.
# Papdadap da dadadada
# Wenn jemand am Telefon
zu leise spricht - oder zu laut
# Wenn man mir sagt, ich sehe
ohne Make-up - viel besser aus
Wenn ihr also richtige Musik
hören wollt, schaut gerne vorbei.
Nächste Woche geht es sich hier
weiter mit richtiger Wissenschaft.
Wenn ihr
bis dahin nicht warten können,
schaut einfach dieses Video.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.